robert h richards iv
raped and sexually abused his
four-year-old daughter for the last time
as he had before he warned her to keep
this a secret
but this time she didn't she told her
grandmother
who told her mother who told their
pediatrician
who told the police richards was
arrested
and charged with two counts of
second-degree rape punishable by a
minimum prison term
of 20 years but richards
an heir to the 16 billion dupont family
fortune
didn't get anywhere near the minimum of
20 years in jail
in fact he got none at all he pled
guilty to a charge of rape in the fourth
degree
paid a fine of 4 395
and promised to attend a high-end
treatment center in massachusetts
which he technically couldn't because he
wasn't allowed to leave the state of
delaware
so that's where he stayed receiving
psychiatric care and group counseling
for sex offenders
and this all stayed under the radar for
six whole years
[Music]
dupont family history goes back to the
french revolution
the duponts were actually very close
with louis xvi
who was executed during the french
revolution so after he was executed
the dupont family decided to flee france
and they came to the united states
the dupont company which originally
manufactured gunpowder
transitioned into a chemical giant and
today has revenues of 21.5 billion
dollars
the family is huge around 4 000 members
share the 16 billion family fortune
they've had notable members like pete
dupont the former governor of delaware
but they've also had their share of
criminals like john dupont who was found
guilty of the murder of olympic gold
medalist david schultz
and he later died in jail and while it
took a few years
the unemployed tier 2 sex offender
robert richards
living off the family trust fund was now
in the public eye
a rich man walks free after he
admits he rapes his three-year-old
little girl
are you aware the dupont family owns
delaware
pretty much very wealthy the public
outrage started in 2014
when the mother of robert richard's
children filed a civil lawsuit
asking for monetary damages for robert's
crime this was the first time the
general public heard about the 2008 case
we don't know why local media
missed the news it's not easy
the civil suit revealed that
during his psychiatric treatment robert
was actually not really revealing
all of his thoughts and in 2010
his sex offender counselor asked for a
polygraph
in which it was revealed that robert may
have also
touched his younger son but
for whatever the reason the further
allegations
were investigated but they never led to
another charge so the words that
the judge said at the time was you know
you have incredible family support and
you should be grateful for that and you
should get treated
so a lot of people said is this the type
of treatment
that someone else would have gotten so i
dug into this i reached out to the
police department that was investigating
this i
also reached out to robert richards
himself and
no one would comment on this eugene
moore did not want to talk to me
i also reached out to judge jan jordan
who presided over the case at the time
for comment and
she wouldn't comment any further on the
case
and it is you know almost impossible
when no one talks to you it's almost
impossible
to find out if he actually did get
special treatment
but even though we don't know that what
we know is that he had access
to the best lawyer in delaware and
only the richest people can do that
so he had that in his favor
the fact that he could tap into any
source
that he could eugene j moore jr
is known as one of the most prolific
defense attorneys in delaware
famously defending stephen b pennell the
delaware serial killer
as well as former delaware deputy
attorney general thomas capano
who was found guilty of murdering his
girlfriend
during richard's sentencing moore called
the six foot four
nearly 300 pound richards a somewhat
gentle person
and argued he would not fare well in
jail
hours later richards walked away from
delaware superior court
a free man
but now that this was all made public
people wanted answers
judge jan jordan took much of the heat
getting so many threats
she ended up hiring private security
detail
in addition beau biden acting attorney
general at the time
also received much scrutiny so much so
he published an op-ed in delaware's the
news journal
defending the punishment meaning
if this case went to trial and roberts
was found not guilty
he would have walked away free without
any restrictions but by not bringing the
case to trial
the court was able to nearly guarantee
he would be registered as a sex offender
receive counseling and be on probation
and parole
one thing that i found out when i was
talking to an expert who looks at crimes
against
children that it is very hard to convict
someone
when the victim is a minor and is very
very young because
children at very young ages are not
really considered
strong witnesses so in the case of
the rape of a minor it is easier
for someone to make a case that they are
not guilty in robert's case
already pleaded guilty but again the
current system
kind of enabled him to
get away with a smaller
punishment in comparison to jail time
[Music]
you